here in New Orleans people treat tables
like troughs and act like a horse fished
together there's all these tables over
here and people a lot of people go to
dinner for crawfish on the tables and if
people gonna eat it like beasts and most
of these people look like they have
shops they're gonna eat it off the
suspects tables that have already had
clownfish autumn hey hey man - how you
do I'm not doing this [ __ ] though man
it's pretty crazy to lots so the way for
them was down to drop this possession is
done the crazy
well relief better around for a long
time no profit I'm here at home
not even walk route fish I've never been
so disappointed to not see something
that added evil one
we couldn't get the crawfish with it so
here's some footage from people just
doing other girl [ __ ] oh my god hi I'm
Bill O'Reilly thanks for watching
porcupine reps I'm a snap [ __ ] around
with my dog porcupine Wilma can organize
this game therefore I suspect as fact is
that false is true for planets for crash
was fun